[Music]  the high bar was set by rachel zegler on  the first day of casting  and i just kept looking and looking and  looking and she was the bar that no one  reached no one could reach as high as  rachel reached that first day  i feel pretty  awesome  i cast rachel when she was 17. she was a  senior in high school when she got the  part  and i could not believe that somebody  who could sing as well as that  and who looked a part of maria  how could i be so lucky to find her on  my first day of casting  you should know better  you are in love everything that rachel  sings comes from in here  you know this is just a gateway but it  really begins inside  when she began singing live on that song  i just tears  not just me everybody around us  tears  [Music]  it's extraordinary to watch her do that  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  you